hi I'm uh
I'm Mel Brooks yeah the guy who brought
you the producers young Frankenstein's
Spaceballs and Blazing Saddles and now I
am proud to present the long anticipated
follow-up to my film history of the
World Part One we're calling it history
of the World Part Two
roll it I've got some marketing
materials to show you let's just jump
right into it where's Noah hey guys
Jesus Judas General Grant Mary Magdalene
Princess Anastasia Sigmund Freud
Amelia Earhart Marco and the other guy
says Polo it's better in a pool
hands up where I can see him good gravy
is Harriet Tubman Harriet Tubman the
inventor of the bathtub
these dumbasses enslave us
so call me Jesus Christ Son of God some
call him broken corny that woman is
enchanting you rabby [ __ ]
anything else are we trapping
good job hey hey
who is this your mama if you're my
mother what is your last name no that's
my mother that confirms it
all
oh
[Music]
you're a virgin
wow wow wow
you want Jesus to be white that's not
what I'm saying don't you put words in
my mouth history of the World Part Two
part two if this was on that fish I
would cancel my subscription
foreign
[Music]